the US air sports has told a sergeant
that he's gonna actually have to leave
the military unless he agrees to take an
oath with the phrase so help me God yeah
I'm not making that up no other branch
of the military forces uh their members
to do this but the US military uh but
the Air Force does uh he's refusing to
do that and now he's poised to take the
military to court uh Jacqueline
obviously has to start with you on this
one what chip relation churches yeah
there's that thing we call separation
and people don't even realize what that
is I don't think I mean how could you
really sit there and expect somebody to
have to even put their hand on a Bible
when they're going under oath to your
version of God you know what if they
want to put their hand on a Bible for
you know Thor or some other ridiculous
made-up or than gone yeah I mean I
pledge allegiance to the flag you know
one nation under Thor how about that
let's do that right so should we I
always say we should have to swear on
the Constitution that would make a
little more sense those are the law all
right that we're supposed to live under
but instead it's just this imaginary
book and I don't even mean that to
denigrate religious people but it has
nothing to do with our laws so what is
what is about the u.s. air force that
that's the one I thought was interesting
here that it's not the other branches of
the military it's just the Air Force
it's the only one that I understand why
it is specifically the Air Force I mean
look what is it about them that they are
they the most to God and that what it is
that they're seeking Yogi's up there oh
yeah and they're flying around up there
like we maintain this like no I don't
understand it all and I can't believe
this is still still in place and you're
saying why can't people understand it's
a separation between church and state
because there isn't actually a
separation between church and state in
every in our courtrooms in you know in
our Pledge of Allegiance yeah in our
classrooms it's like it's everywhere
yeah and by the way for people that
might think that things are going in the
right direction in terms of church and
state uh actually in the past you were
allowed to use alternative phrases
instead of so help me God but they
changed their policy in October 2013
yeah less than a year ago they made this
thing more religious so that's sort of
the the order that we're going here
do you think it really though is it a
violation of the Constitution I mean if
this guy's gonna sue and I think he's
gonna win yeah he should win it is a
violation it's blatantly not okay to do
that I mean there's somebody here
willing to risk their lives for our
country and he's actually being forced
to go against something he believes and
you know he's giving it been given
ultimatum I think he absolutely has a
case and he should absolutely went yeah
all right well we've got a little bit
more on atheists because a third of
Americans want God taken out of the
Pledge of Allegiance I thought this was
really interesting yeah actually the
phrase under God was only added to the
Pledge of Allegiance in 1954 so it
wasn't always there contrary to popular
belief and there was a study on this
let's take a look at findings the
American Humanist Association surveyed a
thousand Americans after being told
those words were added to the original
version 34 percent said under God should
be removed 66 percent said it should
stay and of the thousand responded 666
oh the devil the devil the devil
identified themselves as Christian 123
as followers of other faiths and two
hundred eleven were unaffiliated so your
point a second ago about we don't even
have a separation of church and say
direct that's what you were saying
actually does this by as an atheist when
you see the Pledge of Allegiance and
they and does this bother you does the
phrase bother ya it bothers me because
it's you know this is not one nation
under God this is one nation with a
variety of different people with a
variety of different beliefs or lack of
belief so why would we want something in
there that's exclusionary and I liked I
liked you know the American Humanist
Association saying that there were a
third of people that wanted it out that
made me feel kind of better but at the
same time I thought was kind of [ __ ]
like I mean I'm used to being in such
like a Christian society and stuff and I
kind of looked into their numbers a
little bit I'm like this just doesn't
make sense no way it's a really a third
of people out there who want this to be
like that and they said something like
just real quick are you say are you
saying that because you think that
numbers low like you were surprised no I
thought that was high because I'm sure
I'm like shocked that I'm
just I'm saddened by the fact that it's
so low I couldn't believe it was as high
as it was I thought that was absolutely
like I was like did they fudge the
numbers to make it look more favorable
towards you know secularism and they
said that what 666 were Christians of
the thousand so that's what roughly like
two thirds yeah but that's not right
because eighty three percent of the
population in America is Christian so
their numbers are skewed a little bit so
use right so their internal polling data
you're saying is skewed right
unfortunately it's just not yeah but I
mean I think you can be Christian and
still want the word God taken out yeah
well I guess you could be anything I
wanted yeah I think it's not about that
I think you can be Christian and just
still be you know open-minded to the
fact that this is essentially becoming a
statement of faith instead of a pledge
to our allegiance of nation you know and
and that's not what it's supposed to be
about and it you get into freedom of
speech issues in my opinion you know
when you're you're making children I'm
I'm sorry I know people say that kids
aren't required to say the Pledge of
Allegiance but maybe things have changed
in the couple of years that I've been a
child but I I mean I was forced to say
the Pledge of Allegiance every morning
with my hand over my heart like it was
like that was what you're doing right
even if you didn't if you were the one
kid that didn't well then you'd be
bullied all day for not doing it right
or suspended or something of that but
really it's amazing to me that we don't
have the debate more about why don't we
say one nation under the Constitution
that is the book that is the document or
so you just want it out altogether mean
the whole thing wasn't there before like
we 1954 yeah so why do we need to just
add that in just take the whole segment
out one nation indivisible with liberty
and justice for all
yeah is it does it have something to do
with kind of like if you throw God in
there then it's kind of like you can
make people believe anything like one
nation under God yeah whatever it means
whatever you want it to mean so it's
sort of how like if they were to put
constitution in there then our
politicians would actually have to
follow the Constitution but they don't
have to they have to follow God I think
there's using God
in their mind the way that they
legitimize is that they use God as like
this big balloon term and God being the
nation that we live in like the
omnipotent presence that we are part of
but at the same time it's like not
comfortable for some people to say that
you know I mean like imagine if all
those Christians had to say like one
nation under Allah or whatever and some
people would be uncomfortable well
imagine those people being put in that
situation it's the same thing it should
just be an in descript term they all
have a majority rules mentality and with
eighty percent eighty three percent
being Christian it's kind of difficult
to get around that sometimes and I think
there was actually a similar study done
before this and the result was like what
eight percent people said they wanted to
have it taken out right so they jumped
from eight percent to thirty four
percent
see anything Goods happening here
actually is that I don't sort of shine
but okay so the point of this was to
show that with education people's minds
would open to wanting to take it out so
the poll originally that got eight
percent as a result they didn't educate
people and tell them that it's been
changed since 1954 so what the American
Humanist Association did was they said
hey this didn't always used to be there
this was something that was added in it
wasn't always there and with this new
information the point they were trying
to make is that people were more open to
saying okay well then maybe we should
take it out because it does seem weird
that it's in there because I guess it
wasn't there all along it's almost as if
if you educate people they become
smarter
you